my guest today is larry mazza former
hitman for gregory scarpa who was a
former couple for the colombo family
known as the green reaper
uh some said he said he stopped counting
after 50 hits this is his protoje today
some say he had over 200 hits
there's a lot of story speculation aids
kkk
robert de niro contacted through his
associates to have larry mazza help him
out as a consultant for the irishman we
have a lot of things to cover today
having said that larry thank you so much
for being a guest somebody team it's
great to have you i'm so happy to be
here
[Music]
obviously i've read a ton and i've
researched a ton on you to see what your
background is and we've interviewed a
lot of different people
uh from your world but for the listeners
the viewers that don't yet know your
story kind of walk us through upbringing
where you're from and how you got
connected to the model well
my upbringing is uh very very normal
very basic uh i had a my my dad was a
lieutenant fire department in new york
my mom
worked in a bank i went to catholic
school along with my sister and brother
uh
you know we had a you know no really was
no crime uh i didn't have anything but a
bright future ahead of me
i played ball i was a martial artist
then i went on to coach younger kids uh
my brother's age and younger
and you know uh just uh i i actually
wound up going to college eventually too
and uh john jay college criminal justice
yeah criminal justice is what you were
studying i saw that yeah so i had taken
the fire department test so growing up i
mean nobody would have ever thought
that i would have wound up in the life i
wound up in if i'm in 10th grade with
you who were you you said ball like you
played basically football baseball every
sport except hockey ice hockey were you
popular with the girls were you the
grades were you the i got great
bodybuilder were you the body guy who
who were you know really a little of
everything okay we worked out every day
uh like i said i was in a karate school
with a champion kickboxer named lou
neglia most people know who that is i
moved on to other places after him and
continued my whole life with it uh i did
lift weights uh i played football i
played basketball uh you know
like i said we did go to the weight gym
every night eventually i became a
trainer a personal trainer and uh i
still do that to this day personal
training today yeah so so you're doing
all of that you know you're going to
school college trying to be a
lawyer is that kind of the direction
where you want to be more i was taking
i was taking uh uh police science fire
science my father always said to me
whatever i do because i said i was the
smartest one he said out of my sister
and brother they both became successes
in the real world and i
was heading towards success in that life
until the you know it all caved in on us
but he said i could have been a a chief
fire chief i said i would have moved
right up the ladder because i grip
progressed things without even studying
i didn't have to hit the books for hours
and hours and hours i would go to school
take notes and and ace my tests you know
so i definitely had a bright future you
know when i was working i worked through
high school i worked through college and
that's sort of what led me into this
other life that i wound up in later on
and and the the life happens through you
meeting linda first is that kind of how
you yes so what happens how do you meet
linda who is linda and what is it
linda at first to me was just a very
beautiful older woman and i say that
because she was a little over 30 maybe
and i was only 17 going on 18. so i was
a kid
and i was working at a supermarket
i was about to graduate high school and
go on to john jay
so on my
route i would deliver groceries to her
house
and then she'd come into the supermarket
little by little she got more and more
friendly with me
and ultimately on one of the
deliveries to her house she really
opened up to me she sat me down she
offered me a drink
which i didn't have i had iced tea or
something but she had i wanted to you
know vodka or something i said no i'm
still working naive kid you know
a few years later i said oh yeah bring
me the drink you know but i uh i knew i
had to get back to work
and
ultimately she asked me straight out
if i fool around
and being so young and naive my answer
to her was i'll never forget it because
she busted out laughing and she wound up
telling her husband not to fast forward
later on about this
so i don't know she's married at this
time uh i says of course i fool around
do i look gay to you i says i'm you told
him yeah yeah but again you know i was a
naive kid didn't know any better so she
laughed
now this is somebody you're attracted to
this is somebody yeah no no i mean she's
a beautiful beautiful lady nothing's
happened yet nothing's happened no this
was the first break and then she says
well she wanted my number and i gave i
gave it to her and she used the uh if i
ever need to call you at the store to
bring something over for me would you do
it of course you know i'd live here
anyway you know
funny thing is
the next night she wants me to come over
the house and i got to go to school i
got
kickboxing and i got the gym and i'm
trying to tell her no i can't you're a
senior in high school you yes
so i'll never forget i'm in bed beach
bodybuilding on avenue okay and i get a
phone call
she tracked me down today
because she knew where i worked out
and i get a phone call larry mazza you
come to the front desk you have a phone
call okay who now is calling me the gym
every you know i go up there it's her
and she wants me to come over after the
gym
i'm still trying to fight it i says i
got to go home and shower i got homework
to do long story short i go home i take
a shower i ask my father for the car
keys that young he gives me the keys
and i go to her house
and
that night is where the romance started
okay she had a bottle of wine out uh i
remember there was a joint in the uh
ashtray which i had never even seen it
what year is this this is 78 got it 78 i
never even saw a joint until 78. until
that one wow born in 61. yeah yeah so
uh i told her the wine was good i had a
cup a little wine with her and there's
little snacks like the famous m ms i
talk about that everybody laughs about
it but i remember that's what was on the
table
and uh it was a phenomenal night you
know the chemistry if you think about it
for a young kid like that with a woman
that knows the ropes already uh
it's just phenomenal so that went on
it's just like your professor at that
time yeah yeah yeah
somebody uh uh compared it to a movie
called the graduate yeah from years ago
yeah yeah that's mandatory for uh yeah
it's it was similar and
you know at first we went on for weeks
and weeks uh i never even cared i had to
assume inside she was married you know
uh
eventually she might have mentioned the
kids something early on that i suck
she's married but i never
really
pursued that i thought that was on her
maybe he's traveling maybe he's a
salesman maybe whatever i'm just you
know i i really didn't care it's not
nice to say that but you know as a young
kid like that i was it was when that
happened are you telling that to anybody
or no like are you coming back telling
your friends guys you won't know what
happened my partner jimmy yeah who
worked with me he came he's right
through the whole book with me till the
end the jail time everything the war
he was working with me at dances
so he knew
but it was unspoken okay
when we found out who he was
which jim is this jimmy jimmy jimmy my
partner jimmy from the book yeah jimmy
dumas yeah so he knows what's going on
the entire time he knows he's the only
one others started speculating some of
my close friends but once later on he
fast forward they knew he was everybody
just shut up nobody would even discuss
it but you're like jimmy knew he saw me
with her in the store together he knew i
would when it was delivered to the house
i said i got this one you know things
like that and he knew but like i said
it's unspoken uh
so
now
it turns into months
and
we're getting really closer we're
getting closer i'm not gonna say we're
madly in love but it's turning into a
real
uh real feelings
and
she starts opening up to me about her
she has a husband so i said yeah i
figured that but you know uh
they didn't live together in that house
i'm assuming i was i never saw him there
okay at the beginning okay like i said
it's about six months where we were just
living like it was just us two i knew
what nights i could come
now
later on later on i'm telling you how i
felt at the time later on as you start
looking back at certain things those
times i thought i heard a crack in the
house or i thought i heard something she
said oh no no it's an old house you know
it's whatever the house is still
settling that's not true you know maybe
he was there maybe he was downstairs
there was a a a basement apartment later
on that i knew he would go into a lot
okay
but while we're talking about this so
people can understand he already had
another wife that i yeah i found out
about later on and i'll get to that so
so this goes on for about six months
and
now she wants me to drop everything
i can't go with other girls you don't
need school anymore you're gonna be this
we have a business we're opening up
her husband and her she's going to be
the name on it they want me to be the
regional sales manager so she wants me
to meet him and she starts telling me
he's an influential guy
he can take you to a lot of good places
he knows a lot of people i still don't
get it i'm figuring oh maybe he's a big
doctor or something
you know that knows a lot of people
so
after a few more months goes by still
the same thing
i'm eventually to cut to the chase that
says okay i'll meet him i fought it for
months i said i can't meet your husband
this is not right i said well now i know
it's wrong i mean now you're bringing me
to a whole different situation
so finally one night we go to an italian
restaurant okay well before let me tell
you what happens i get to the house
about five o'clock
and i know i'm gonna meet him this night
okay and i still don't know what he is
so i'm standing at the front door and i
did have a vodka i'll never forget that
i said i'll have a vodka because i
wanted to calm down a little bit i'm
going to meet the husband of a woman on
sleeping with almost a year
and i'm looking out the window
i see a big black fleetwood broom pull
up
big caddy spoke wheels
dark windows
pulls in
and i'm watching i want to see what he
looks like at that first impression
he gets out of the car dark sunglasses
it's dark out at night he's still got
dark sunglasses on
sport jacket dressed like
he once told me john gotti learned how
to dress for me okay later on
dressed just like that i mean shop
and i won't say he walked to the door
because it was more of a swagger
he had a presence in his walk that as he
was coming to the door it registered i
said this is not because i had an
uncloud but who's around guys like this
and i said this is no doctor or salesman
i said you know and later on i had said
if you look in the dictionary uh on the
mobster there's a picture of him
model uh what's that other word uh
uh just a perfect example of a
of a gangster
so he comes up the steps
i open the door
and i put my hand out i says uh i'm
larry
he says i'm greg
so we shake hands he smiles very nice
happy to meet me but all along i thought
his name was charles
that's the first
time i learned his name was greg she
told you it's charles she told me he was
charles got it okay charles shearer
there's a whole story behind that and i
i you know it's not even my place to get
into it but with an ex
husband or an ex-boyfriend but
he was
charles shiro to me up until that minute
so he goes in he's gonna
freshen up change a little bit whatever
he goes in i go to linde i said lin i
thought his name was greg
he said he's charlie i i s charlie i
thought you know she says oh no he just
uses that name charlie
i says people just use all the names i
it's like she said it like it's normal
you still don't know what he does no no
but like i said that struck to the house
i said this is a man's man i mean it's a
guy got it you know
so
he comes back in and he has two scotches
now i had vodka i even then i didn't
want to mix but i didn't say no i took a
scotch and we sipped it together he
talked a little bit he started telling
me about the company we're going to meet
these two guys one's a lawyer one's an
accountant they're all on the board of
this company very real and it wasn't it
turned out to be real uh so anyway that
night i meet him and we go to the
restaurant
so she walked into the car she goes to
grab my arm
and i had to move away from the lake
like what are you doing yeah he was in
front of us let's walk behind him
so anyway we get to the restaurant
and
i meet the two fellows and he doesn't
recommend he doesn't
say i want to propose larry to be the
sales manager
he tells them both uh larry's going to
be our sales manager
i said okay that's i didn't need a
resume or anything you've never sold
you've never done no no no well you are
now yeah
yeah
so yeah so and you got a promotion
yourself managers i was sales manager
right off the bat
so
anyway after this night i start working
for him and he tells me i have to come
to the office every day which turns out
to be a social club so i start meeting
other guys and i'll get more into that
but before all this happens you know i'm
going out to different avenues
they give me a list of addresses to go
to where i can uh service their fire
extinguisher and then try to sell them
paper products
and
the the addresses they gave me were all
hot i was going to get them i walked in
they were expecting me i got the account
so i built a little portfolio right off
the bat
if they didn't say yes
or i went to a place called they told me
you can go into other stores in the same
area but start with this one it's a yes
and they would tell me no i'd go back to
the club and i'd say well these four
guys weren't interested and greg says
all right carmine post carmine in
carmine gets the addresses go back there
the next day go back again tomorrow i go
back the next day they treat me like uh
i don't see al capone like a senator a
neighborhood
uh politician are you speculating at
this time like what's going on of course
no no now i see the club i know he's i
know he's you know he's connected at
this point yeah okay yeah again i know
he's what he is was greg a known face
and a name that you no he's a low-key
guy he's located is he a cowboy at that
time or not no he never i'm gonna tell
you he never became a capital until the
very end got it okay they bypassed him
for his son
something i thought they asked him about
okay and yeah greg jr told me no they
bypassed my father and this discussion
came
because of what came out years later and
i don't want to tip my mission let's get
to that show so yeah yeah uh
so uh now i got this position i see the
influence i'm getting these uh uh
accounts
and this goes on for a few months but
while it's going on he's helping me he's
building me up he's telling these other
guys about me that i'm his nephew and we
treat him you know i mean it's off the
charts
so i start feeling very very guilty and
i'm starting to
tell linda we have to stop we can't do
this this isn't right i mean i i can't
go on like this
she's persuasive talks me out of it we
wind up making love and i'm back again
and it's just not like again that i
wanted to get away but i just knew it
wasn't right
so
finally she starts telling me
she wants to let him know about us
okay and of course i fight that i says
no i mean he's not please you want to
get me killed i mean this is i know and
she laughs he would never do that he
loves you anything i love he loves you
know giving me little hints that
possibly
he knows and i at that point i have no
idea okay and i still don't know the
real exact truth okay
so we
uh continue for a few more months few
more months now he sees me getting
erratic
i don't show up where i'm supposed to
show up because i think he's going to
kill me okay because now i started
seeing little things you know guys get
thrown out kicked out maybe cracked
around you know not major violence but
in the club the office
i may see one of the shylocks who's
hanging around
you know grabbing a guy by the throat
so i know it's not a nice nobody's
gotten killed yet though no one's gotten
shot or you haven't seen anything no
nothing like that yet but like i said i
have an uncle albert who's a dinosaur
with the uh colombo family he went back
all the way to junior persico's rise
as a matter of fact there's a scene in a
movie
well the godfather where
the guy's getting choked
at the bar
junior persico was doing the choking
my uncle albert was in the crash car
outside
you know in real life
yeah yeah so he was tight with junior
from way way back uh
so
i knew it could i knew there was deaths
and
guys get killed you know brooklyn you
know especially back then you'd see a
body every couple of weeks somewhere you
know it wasn't odd and i didn't want to
be one of those bodies i started getting
paranoid so what year is this is this 80
already or not not quite 79 79 pushing
80 yen okay about 18 months after we met
so you're 18 and a half 19 at this point
yes exactly and uh
so now
what happens is like i said he starts
seeing it so he starts saying things to
me little by little i don't like what's
what i see is something wrong you got to
talk to me and i keep letting it go
letting it go
finally
uh there's one specific instance where i
didn't show up and he was going to hit
somebody that night or they rounded him
all i had to do was drive him downtown
just drop me off
and i didn't show up
okay
and i found out later on
a friend bucky was killed that night
okay he was going to have me drop him
off there and and if you if you follow
the mo as years go by
they give you little little bit little
tiny things to do
ultimately to bring you to a certain
level where you're asked to do more so
that little bit of a thing was his first
step
maybe he'd hear about it maybe he won't
very psychological and when you when you
bring your kid in okay and it's usually
an influential
male that you're you're you're following
that brings you in i got brought in by
an influential woman also
so like scarfall brought in leonetti and
leonetti was also young and
you know he was gradually getting him
through but scarfa was a
he was also a brutal guy but not 200
hits like
scarpo with scarpa stopped counting
again
he told me that he stopped counting 50.
then i heard later on you know higher
numbers uh then when i was away with him
and gas pipe uh on mcc they were talking
about numbers between the two of them uh
they said we got over 200 between the
two of us that's where the 200k is this
organizing or is this a leading there's
a big difference to two right what do
you mean so so you you say you say no
they're not authorized you're for
yourself 25 as you were involved in
that's the number that i read about you
right yes what was
a scarplus number he
he was a shooter okay he never asked
anybody else to do the shooting unless
it was for a reason to make their bones
to get them
settled in and understand they they're
capable
he never asked me to go anywhere alone
never asked me to do this never asked me
to even on a beatings well beatings a
lot of time it was greg junior would
would be
he took that
as a badge of honor that he didn't
relegate it or say you're gonna do it he
says he'd get out of the chair say let's
go you know and we'd go with him again
this is later on which i'll get to
so no but he was he was a shooter on the
scene i've
heard about some hits that aren't even
that public
you know that
you know
you can talk about it now everybody's
gone uh i wouldn't hate to cause trouble
for somebody that's why i say that even
though i made a deal with the government
i'm not looking to start trouble for
people uh it was never that way uh
but so anyway going back to this night
that was a pivotal night he knew
something was wrong with me
so she started telling me again
we're going to tell him we're going to
tell him and i made a comment back then
i said get me a bulletproof vest first
please because you can't tell him i mean
you know he's now it he's got to kill me
sarcastic or seriously i was half
serious yeah
you know i just uh
so finally one day i get to the house
well what happens is
the supply company
has a big problem at the factory it
burns down
okay to this day i don't know if it was
done on purpose yeah you know in
hindsight
probably probably a big insurance check
uh it's the mo nobody really wants
legitimacy very common strategy right
right right so
now i'm in no man's land
okay i left college for this the fire
department test that i was very high on
i got a 99 underwritten and a 95 on the
physical now 99 on the written i should
have got 100. it really it wasn't a very
difficult test i started saying that
trying to trick me and
you want to know one of the questions
was okay
you're walking past
a gas station you notice the pump is
leaking you a
stop and light up a cigarette
b ignore it it's none of your business
c call the fire department
d all the above obviously at c so most
of the questions were like that and i
was laughing my way through it the
physical on the other hand guys were
throwing up at the end it was very
difficult so a 95 i'm proud of anyway
i'm high on the list but what happens is
that test
back in the day now this is back in geez
80. i took the test in 80 probably 79
but as soon as i was 18 i took the test
and
it gets thrown out because uh
minorities had a problem with it and
women with the physical so a judge
in the federal courts takes two years to
rule on it
then he rules on it and sets another
test for two more years so four years is
going to go by before i could take the
test again
in that time she knows i'm in no man's
land she tells greg or asks him in front
of me we got to find something for larry
so i never forget the first thing out of
his mouth was
but we could get him in the numbers the
number business is the lowest
form of racket there is
nobody gets hurt there's no credit uh
the biggest problem there is tax evasion
if you have a big number business okay
so i get in it with them
and they give me a few ideas of how to
build up numbers they give me a few
spots that are already working when i
say them it's greg and greg jr because
they're partners
i start
improvising on my own i start going to
and i'm already good with numbers i was
always good with numbers i go to the
local otbs i know there's all gamblers
in there
i go to the bowling alleys because
they're all bowling for money
and i'm picking up numbers and they're
all giving them to me
now i start at the otbs
i start taking horse action otb is off
track betting i don't know if you
remember
yeah it goes way back and it failed in
new york and i couldn't understand how
later on in life how you're losing a
gambling proposition anyway so i start
not picking up horses so now i'm
bringing horses in i'm bringing
and i still don't have enough i get the
football tickets
okay the paul a cards again lowest form
of racket you could do but now i'm
making 500 800 a week back in
80. all cash yep
and i don't have to tell my parents i'm
not the manager anymore so i'm still
making a living and they're not asking
any questions you're living with your
parents i live in the basement apartment
got it yeah and
you know so now there's really nothing
looks out of ordinary other than
my first caddy when i pulled him with
the first caddy i said no it comes with
the company you know and i've said along
the way
i said along the way and i don't mean it
in a bad way because i don't
consider myself a liar by no means i try
to be honest and ethical whatever the
word is i got a lot of people that'll
attest to that
but certain situations you become a good
liar
like that with your parents
your wife your girlfriend you have to
so you wind up saying things that aren't
true and just living with it and going
on you know
so
anyway i start
bringing the football tickets out now
i'm giving them to my friends to also
give out and also take numbers they're
all in different otb's so we're building
a little mini thing where now i'm
bringing in thousands a few thousand two
three thousand numbers and horses and
sports
the next level
is now booking sports okay now this all
took a little bit of time
so but this was how he opened the door
for me i'll never forget his words but
we could get him in the numbers he's
telling linda that to appease her
and he gets me in the numbers and
i thrived with all of that stuff
so
uh
now
this one day he's bringing me to the
club
okay we're in the car
and he starts telling me larry
you know i love you like a son
okay you're very mature for your age and
i'm gonna have this conversation with
you because i know you can handle it i
know where he's going i know where he's
going and i feel the butterflies linda's
not in the car just you and him just me
and him going to the club like every day
we get there at 12 30 the rest of the
guys come at one uh it's just because he
would be there already
and sometimes one other guy was there
bobby but he wasn't there to stay so
we're driving there and i'm just being
quiet i'm actually like looking out the
window wondering what do i do now i said
this is it you know
you take me to the club and
i think i'm gonna get killed
so
he's just talking about it doesn't say
he's going on how linda cares about you
and we're not that far from the club to
the house you know if there's no traffic
it's less than 10 minutes you know
uh so we get to the club now and we walk
in
just like this we're sitting like me and
you he goes behind the desk he's got his
big seat and i got a chair just like
this and i sit down and he's telling me
he says
i want you to know i know about you and
linda
so
i had a choice right there
okay i could have got up and run you
know which i didn't do
but i said to myself i've never forget
it's my moment of truth
this you know i still care for her i
don't want it to be over he
and i looked at him i said these are my
exact words okay it says greg
you're far from an idiot
and i have a lot of respect for you
you're far from an idiot only an idiot
wouldn't see this
he hit the test he starts laughing he
gets up i'm still a little nervous we
walk out together he puts his arm around
me okay we walk out in front of the club
it's just us too outside this is a
ritual for us he got himself set up he
put his paperwork away you know
we go outside
and we're leaning on the parking meter
okay that's something we did you know
we've taken the sun
i was and he uh
goes on to tell me he's okay with this
because but the only thing is only the
three of us could ever know about it
he says if anybody else finds out you
and i will be killed
why you and i
well because he's breaking the rule too
he's breaking the rule by allowing it
okay uh and at that point i didn't i
mean i understand he's a made man he's
amazing you're not yet okay no he's a
made guy all the way is he an earner or
is he a racketeer or is he more the the
he's been described by that by others
including like sammy the bull he's what
he talked about our club he says that
13th avenue club were racketeers and
killers and it's a lethal it's about
lethal obviously but it's a it's a
combination uh the consummate that's the
word i was looking for before the ones
that everybody looks up to and fears and
respects yeah you know and we weren't
the only ones i'm not saying that no no
we were in that category everybody in
there if you're under greg
okay if he calls you with him you're
with me okay he introduces you to others
even it's a friend of mine at the
beginning you get the same respect as
anybody does and you're expected to
produce uh not only earn but carry
yourself like a good fella even if
you're not yet and
and and eventually you're going to be
hurting people and killing people just
the way it is if you're in that club
yeah in a circle it's going to happen
and it happened to me and we'll we'll
get there as we go so now um ernie with
him
i feel the weight of the world off my
shoulders
you know because we're able to go on and
we go on are three of you ever talking
about it openly when you're around each
other or no yeah so and let me ask you a
couple questions here so
uh uh one when i look at his background
he was married to connie and they
separated and he had been with linda for
30 years and connie had three kids
junior is one of them and with linda
they had two kids but i don't think they
ever officially got married with linda
right that's true okay so they were not
it was i didn't know that back then
later when i found out it was just
common law but
he never officially divorced connie
never did okay yeah all those nights he
was somewhere but there's a third wife
in there you knew that of course lily
yes okay the middle east and beauty yes
yeah yes so
a lot of time not a lot of times but
several times i took him to the airport
and she was in vegas
so he'd be gone for a day or two
other times he'd be picked up in a limo
uh and taken to manhattan and i wouldn't
see him for a day or two so he was
juggling to some point he spent every
full weekend in lakewood
you know with connie sure so you know
there's four or five nights a week i was
free to you know but there was also
later on nights where i said i knew he
came home and went in the basement
because i was there already
and we would we would actually meet
for coffee
with the three of you yeah yeah but but
never the three of you at this you know
there was nothing where you know uh uh
uh uh three of you other girls getting
involved that never happened okay and
that came that changes the game if you
guys want that song
once for a very short time and i
shrugged it off as somebody to write in
a book or trying to uh
make right of something that was wrong
but i don't see how that makes it any
better i mean you know to each his own
but no no i'm thinking if you guys
brought another person in to support the
cast no okay so the reason why i asked
i'm trying to get the dynamics here with
this story because uh uh uh
swingers you know you get the swings i
remember one time i had a client of mine
i was
doing business with them and i sold them
to insurance policies and rolled over
their 401k at the end the guy says what
are you doing friday night yeah yeah and
i said you know i got no plans you want
to come over i said what do you have in
mind my wife likes you i said you know i
like you guys you guys are good clients
she says no no she likes you and we'd
like to watch i'd like to watch no i
said okay was that then were they
swingers type of thing i never saw that
uh i don't i don't believe it yeah i
don't think uh i think it was one of
those
i'm gonna say this maybe just a special
moment in time where i think i helped
him because he was juggling he wasn't
her age you don't forget he's 20 years
20 years old yeah he's in his 250 that's
right you know
did linda know about connie of course
yes did connie know about linda no and
if you want and we'll fast forward again
wow towards the very end when it all
came out and greg was in the hospital
and close to death
connie got on the phone with me because
she knew i was his closest guy okay he
said it to everybody
at that point in time i was the closest
guy he ever had in this life which was
incredible you know we were i mean we
went through the war which we're gonna
get to uh you're the only one that cried
right that he told you yeah
when he got when he got uh contracted
the aids virus yeah i cried yeah it's
like a father my father would i would
have cried too i mean you know uh and he
said that himself he says it was
incredible he was touching to him but
this is how he had gotten you know uh so
i think
i was helping him in a way
uh in what way define that well that
keep her busy
four nights a week he's not there
she's got to be wondering where she's a
young girl
so
almost guilt
now they're almost not even playing
field again this is all my opinion
because it's never come out it's never
come out from him or her or anybody that
they knew all along and
i saw little things that make me wonder
if they knew and maybe he did get turned
on by it i don't know or maybe not
turned on by maybe he it satisfied him
that a younger guy wanted his his trophy
so bad yeah when i hear stories like
this they're very random and weird right
because you know when you listen to okay
you know uh the the graduate dustin
hoffman you're like oh you know like uh
young boys you know like dreams like oh
my gosh that teacher yeah it'd be
everybody has that one teacher like oh
my gosh you know what if one day i stay
after school you know you know what my
father said i don't need to interrupt
yeah but he said based on what you're
saying he says he doesn't know if he
could have turned that down my father is
just a legitimate lieutenant great
father great man
never you know a criminal and he said
you know so just on my behalf he said
that and for the audience to kind of uh
have get some of the optics
linda was more like michelle pfeiffer
from scarface was she like the
was she that personality without the
drugs like extremely attractive
seductive and scenario yeah and and love
the life love the money not that there's
anything where everybody likes money i
hate when i hear that but so you know uh
but she
really
it was that was all provocative to her
two other questions on this part here
one of them is so it wasn't that
this is pre the 30 of his associates
coming and getting tested to use blood
mesh to give it to him for the infusion
at this time when this is happening he
doesn't have aids yet so this is free
because when him get engaged so it's not
like they're not having sex because he
doesn't want her to get it right and
it's also not the fact that
uh you know in uh uh in bodybuilding
there was a guy back in the days big
time bodybuilding mr olympia guy when he
got off of everything he couldn't get it
up anymore dude if he took five
diagonals he couldn't do nothing so
there's nothing even you could make a
miracle happen this was not his
challenge either it wasn't like listen i
can't get it out so well i'll tell you
this much i'm just trying to address
every situation and the reason i know
that to some extent is
there was a fourth woman
that used to come to the club
okay
and spend a little time in the office
with him and when he would come out i
mean you could tell he'd give me the
wink you know bobby would say something
bobby was always joking around you know
he'd make a comment
something about the pipes getting
cleaned you know he would just joke all
the time she goes in with her she's
fixed up she comes back
and then later on i heard from uh
uh a relative of greg's i'll just leave
it at that maybe she doesn't want a name
out right now so it's a girl
uh that
he had
another kid
with somebody right on 13th avenue and
it might have been this woman
for what we know that used to come in
she was attractive too but older a
little bit older he was fairly active he
was he had a very high testosterone i
think that was the problem yeah but like
i said i mean at 52
or whatever he was you know you're still
one is yeah but one is is good you know
if you have two all right but four you
know that's you know it's so there's
this but the thing
yeah hey you gotta watch this too now
i became close with the kids i became
joey
the sun made wrestlings
i got close with all the kids but that
family
i became godfather to joey
linda and greg's son
and that was there was a reason for that
other than
it you know to us it was always an
important important person in your life
uh i'm sorry it's a little weird you
know you didn't think it was a little no
i didn't i didn't i really didn't i was
actually honored that you know and in
her eyes maybe i was never gonna have a
kid of my own i was gonna be with her
forever you know but i used to always
tell her i wanted a son i want to have a
kid i want to get married someday and
she didn't want to hear that you know
did she love both of you guys equally or
was it more like he takes care of me but
i love you you know
if i answer that it's unfair it's unfair
i don't think she didn't love greg i'll
say that uh i think she
is lost the word more lust between us
maybe because of the dynamics and the
physical at the ages and stuff but i'm
certain she loved him uh i'm certain he
loved her uh
or cared for her or whatever the word is
because i you know and as years went on
and when all the things went wrong in my
life and i started looking back i
honestly don't know if he loved anything
or anybody you know uh like greg jr i
could see the love with his kids i could
see how he treats other people did he
come out already or he's is it he's
great he's out i've been talking to him
we've got together a few times uh how is
your personalities the two of you guys
together relationships well very similar
he's he's i like to think i'm easy going
he is uh he he likes to laugh you know
his father likes to laugh too
he's easy to talk to and he's caring
he's caring
here's the perfect example i had to
borrow money from greg senior probably
200 times as a kid you know
not once did i not pay vague
really yes not once
even during the war we had to pay big no
breaks nothing okay
greg jr on the other hand i might have
borrowed money from him three times
didn't charge me a penny get out of here
you see you're my brother what's the
matter with you and i'm saying to myself
well i see you know so you fell a little
further than the from the tree than
people thought that's yeah when did greg
know about you and linda
greg jr yeah oh not until the arrests we
all got arrested
and
uh
i
exploded that out there because i had so
much resent for his father
scarborough yeah because ultimately he
was you know a 30-year informant which
we'll get to i'm sure uh and
i was fighting my case
okay later on
i had no intentions of i was gonna make
a deal figure something out 20 years 18
years we're fighting it
but one by one the console year flips
that's carmine cesar who i was fighting
for
uh other
guys goodfellas and captains
finally it comes out that great senior
my mentor the guy that brought me into
this that everything
is a government informer for 30 years
okay
and while i'm on the floor
with the real boss junior persico son
ali boy
he tells me him and his father knew
about greg for 20 years get out of here
i
you know what when he told me that the
cd reaction you just had that must have
came on my face because he turned white
after he said it and he just knew he
made a mistake
terrible thing to tell me that you guys
knew
whether he meant they surmised or they
knew doesn't even matter because people
said well maybe they thought
i've seen guys get killed for a lot
worse
so if you really thought it that's
enough to kill him in that life i hate
to say it
okay i saw greg i watched greg shoot a
guy
that called him a rat
but tried to renege on it at the desk
like we are now i got up out of my chair
when this guy came in he sat down donny
his name was
and
greg took care of his business he took
his money from the guy wrote his name
down crossed him off the list like he
paid
and he says donnie what's this i hear
i'm a rat
donnie turned white he started sweating
he knew he was in trouble
i was standing in the room with greg jr
carmine bobby and one other person great
junior carl my bum oh and me four of us
were in there there were four guys in
the room but i was sitting at the chair
as always i got up to let him sit down
and i would stand right by the door you
know until he left i'd go back and sit
with greg
as soon as the guy said he didn't have
paperwork he was just talking drunk with
another guy i don't mean that you know
better greg you don't have no paperwork
you can't prove that he says no
of course not
reaching his desk drawer right there
pop them right across the table kill
them yep that was the first time i
actually saw somebody get rolled up in a
rug
and carried out
literally and the funny thing is i had
to go with bobby to pick out a new
carpet to put down
and
the color he picked he's colored blind
bobby
we didn't know that he brings an orange
carpet back the last carpet was dark
brown
anyway just something you never didn't
get white yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i
remember that was like a joke for a
while but uh
you know so
so 30 years he's doing that persecuting
them know for 20 years yeah when persico
when this became public
like okay
i'm curious to know what the reaction
was from even snake from
when they found out okay well i'm in the
k i'm in prison at the time
my case well i'll fight my case this is
early on this is pre anything got it
and they bounce you around i'm on the
floor with vic arena
the number one target get out of here
and i'm saying that they had separated
he got out he just got up oh did vic get
out
no no no he no he didn't he's got a
hearing october 13th to see if he can
get he somebody else did get out no but
uh uh
i keep going i'm listening i don't think
it's vicarina
and i'm on separation from everybody i
can't be with
anybody from the other side i can't be
with my partner jimmy i can't be uh well
that was later on when he came in he was
still on the limb anyway they put me on
a phone could be released yeah could be
released from prison
could be released from prison i talked
to his lawyer occasionally go ahead so
uh i'm on the floor with vic
and he calls me oh and we get along you
know we know we're fighting the case and
there's no reason to feud in there i'm
trying to help each other out calls me i
go walking with him i'm walking to the
men's room when you go to the men's room
with a guy they want to talk privately
there's two other guys in there
uh mikey day a friend of mine i want to
use his last name and uh another one uh
i could use his name
if i could think of it uh
he was the console yeah lastorino
uh for the lucasie family
so we go in the bathroom
i said what's up vic he tells me he says
larry is it true i says what are you
talking about he says greg is he a rat
i started going after him that's why
those two were in there they said no
larry just hear him out hear him out
they were hearing her from lawyers they
were hearing it from people and i
[ __ ] fight it excuse me i'm fighting
tooth and nail i don't want to hear it i
said you can't tell you know that's not
good for me either
you know on a selfish note but
so i walk away
my bed was right next to his i took my
mattress i went to the other side
okay and there's all italians here the
other side was mixed whatever i would
rather be there right now from what i
just heard from his mouth okay this is
how arrogant i am about it it's time
the very next day
it comes out in the paper that greg went
in front of the judge okay
and
he was pleading
to be released
he says i you know how much i did for
your government all these years so he
admitted it openly so the next day i get
called back into the bathroom vic's got
the newspaper so i looked at it and
they're asking me did you know
i just shook my head i threw the paper
down i was distraught i walked back to
my corner
funny thing is
i get pulled out of there and i get put
back on the floor with ollie boy and
some of my my co-defendants they all
were on the same indictment
so now we're talking about this and
bobby and guys can't believe it and
ali boy has to be the hero and he tells
me that but i'm going to tell you a
story now
he said 20 years
the paper said 30.
so in my eyes there was an event i never
forgot it i found out later on there had
to be something that happened 20 years
ago
because if he's around for 30 years and
you know something significant happened
later on i find out from an attorney
there's a big big tax case
okay timing is right it's in the 70s it
just works out right eight heavyweights
from the columbo family including junior
persico his brother greg scappy
uh
one of the fusco's some of the russos
all the top names in the family
and it's a big they're gonna face 15 to
20 on this irs charge
they all show up in court
they get the hearing put off all eight
of them are there
they say okay come back and maybe
there's no violence so back then they
had bail whatever you can't get bail
anymore if you're a mob guy
so
they come back maybe four weeks later
six weeks later whatever they put it off
to
they all come in except greg
okay they put it off again
another four to six weeks goes by
they all come back to the hearing except
greg this is the third
hearing
the fourth one gets put back again
they all come in except greg
at that hearing the judge throws out the
case
just throws out the case
so
something had to happen there so now
either
they
call's gonna know there's something
there's something now he's not this is
what i'm leading to right he either
decided that
listen he didn't hurt us
if he had a little connection maybe he
didn't really know how tight it was with
him and his connection maybe he didn't
know when boat weighs maybe he tried to
convince somebody that but now here's
what happens
he becomes
he's a huge earner too he's a tremendous
earner okay so they don't want to throw
that away
but also
any
precarious hit that had to be done
they came to greg
not the one where you get your best
friend or somebody that's who who came
to greg the person goes true scappy yeah
i remember scappy coming in with
different hits that had to be made and
they weren't easy hits at what what
level a hitman is in the in the
italian here's the thing we're not we're
not hit men right i mean these people
call me the hit man i was to me a hit
man does it for money
we didn't do it for money we did it
because it was part of the life if
somebody broke a rule you had it
you had to pay sometimes with your life
uh
indirectly you're gonna rise in the
family and become a captain and maybe
maybe most feared like was was scarpa in
that level of fear he was the most
feared
man in brooklyn probably further and
i've described him as probably being the
most feared guy since al capone i've had
guys come in that club
okay
that are known for chopping up bodies
and all of this
and they
were very very soft-spoken mcgregor
never arrogant never
as a matter of fact one of them he's
dead now so it doesn't matter roy de
mayo he's the one that he's
right yeah everybody
i was just gonna bring it up i wrote his
name there i remember
greg when we had a discussion about that
greg like that's great i
cut up a body why did you know no he'd
rather leave him in the street and let
them see what you know a guy got killed
that was he'd kill you and that's it
he'll walk out you know and go have
dessert these guys had to chop you up
get all the blood out get rid of all the
evidence and stuff that didn't make them
any more brazen
greg would walk into a crowded
restaurant
and shoot two people and walk out no
mask he'd grow a mustache they got these
pictures of him like that's what he had
he glued the mustaches in the skies
he says the first thing i'll never
forget i'm telling you the first thing
they'll say i came in with a mustache so
they'll be looking for a guy with a
mustache forever you know
so uh he was so roy comes in because
gregory and i
uh roughed the guy up that was around
him
loosely he owed me money gambling we
went a few times and we didn't hurt him
bad put him against the wall and
actually gregory did most of the talking
because he was a little older than me
and more convincing
and
very soon after roy came to the club he
comes in the back and i had to sit there
because i knew the details of the debt
i never forget
greg when roy was asking you know for uh
can we pay this off or something like
that greg looked at mrs roy the streets
of us and voice no i'm not here to
dispute that
no he says no right ours meaning wise
guys we'll
take care of it you know we'll take care
we don't need you to make a deal for us
that's what he's leading to we'll
collect the money ourself he said no no
i'll pay it he paid the money for the
guy and got him off the hook
he was there to try to work out a deal
and when greg said the streets were ours
he'd i'd never forget it he like was
like okay yeah greg whatever you say now
not everybody would do that either you
know
i saw greg
when i had a beef with paul castellano's
nephew okay
he
was ready to
he he told paul if a hair is harmed on
his head i'll never forget those words
you'll see more bodies in the street
scappy had to stop greg from talking
because he was going into a very bad
area you know you can't talk to a boss
that way but this was greg you know
nobody was ever going to hurt anybody
around us touch us even if we were told
not to do something
greg was the type we're gonna get this
guy we might have waited two years three
years five years we're gonna get him and
it'll be off the record what was his
personality was he i mean i've seen his
interviews how he speaks he's got a nice
voice yeah was he the uh charming guy
that he's talking and he's kind of
confusing you a little bit and then he
takes you out was he to the point guy
was he the charismatic guy was he what
was his what was his approach
greg was very very
charming
and uh sophisticated he could talk with
anybody i guess what i'm asking you is
like you've seen him right you know how
sometimes the best way to know her to
ask you the best way to know you know
about you is ask her and she'll say well
he's like this and because he's been
she's been watching once you've been
watching her the most you watched scarpa
a lot right yeah
what what tale gave it to you what you
said this guy's about to kill him was
there anything that you said that's his
system he's about to go to a point
or take a guy out what was that tale
well there's one thing that we had
between us and i learned it with him
literally the handkerchief when the
hanky came out of his pocket
and he went make like he was going to
sneeze i knew the guy was in trouble
because when the hanky went back in a
gun was coming out or or the hanky meant
when he put it back in he was getting
hit we had to be ready you know
he was getting killed he's going to hit
the guy and then we're going to finish
him off you know beat give him a beating
uh
but no see greg he was too he could be
two different people okay i said i have
to explain it this way
on 13th avenue
when he was walking the streets or
somebody came in to see him
all business no no joking around
uh
steel
ice in his veins
and he could just look at you
and and and you'll you're convinced that
he means business
you know
on the other hand i can drive around
with him once in a while and well it's
just the two of us in the car
and i could say get the [ __ ] out of here
an [ __ ] you know and he would laugh
that's stupid are you kidding me you
know
but that took years to do it only around
two people though you can't talk like
that with others later on
jimmy caught up to that where jimmy
because what we did during the war got
to that same level where maybe not quite
as much but
where jimmy could make a joke you know
yeah that's smart let's do that you know
and then we all bust out laughing but of
course never in front of others
he trusted the loyalty during the war
between me jimmy and greg was
just you can't even explain it we can't
explain it the closeness and you will
you know we knew we had each other's
back for our lives so what's the ugliest
you saw ugliest hits you saw i know you
saw the one guy that came in he called
him a rat took him out that's one of
them that's probably right up there
because it was right point blank and you
know there was no we weren't prepared
for it really uh you know the ones
during the war i won't really count
because uh you know i was part of them
so
uh
i would say
the one really that i didn't i wasn't at
but i got the description was the girl
that got killed
mary you know that was uh ali ali big
ali's girlfriend uh just the thought of
that i still cringe i mean it's a
horrible thing to think about uh but i
remember him telling me after that he
says you know vividly like details yes
yes yes and he told me what he also told
me was
i didn't
ask you to be on this one you know that
and on the side i'm saying thank you i
said yeah i noticed and he said i know
who's got the stomach for this and who
doesn't know other notable guys that
weren't there either
you know so who was there do do you know
who was there or no like i know well he
was there okay carmine cessa who wanted
to be in the council yeah later on uh
greg jr
uh i
think there was a fourth i'm not sure to
be honest but the ones like that weren't
guys that weren't on things like that
well myself bobby zam i remember him
telling me bobby loves people too much
he also became a captain
you know so i said any anybody under
greg
was good fellow material possibly
captain but
you can't get to what's the reason for
mary the the
well they uh they claimed that mary uh
spoke to the fbi he was on the land with
her for years and he didn't want to
leave where he was he was safe and he
felt that she was
talked to the fbi and she may tell them
where he is so
they claim she was a you know a rat the
big word they want to use all the time
but uh there's no there's no proof of
that either you know it was just in case
and and when when uh when he went away
when uh
ward came out that he's been dealing
with the fbi for 30 years
was that a byproduct who got in trouble
for that like who did he take down
because while he's doing this he's still
taking people out so fbi knows you know
he's doing what he's doing well the ones
that really had the biggest
uh
kickback was was them at the end of the
day the fbi and some prosecutors and uh
maybe even higher than that for allowing
this for allowing a guy like this to
exist and give him caught lunch uh where
he can you know be a i mean a prolific
killer not even a couple of hits here
and there i mean just you know the go-to
guy in the family for for years and
years and years numbers that are unheard
of and uh so no but everybody well me
and jimmy got thrown under the bus okay
and his son
because yeah even greg jr on the
indictment that he went away for okay
every lawyer and every person that knows
anything about the case
wants to know why greg senior wasn't the
boss of that indictment when is scarpa's
birthday
just curious may 11th
or may 8th because him and johnny yeah
good for you yeah yeah yeah yeah good
memory yeah
and uh my father's may 11th and johnny
sapp is may 11th that's i knew there was
a bunch of the same time i'm february
21st so yeah 61. so
61 and i'll be 61.
that's cool so yeah you only get to do
that once that's right 61.61 that's
funny yeah i have to bet that number
legally of course yeah yeah that's right
so yes that's right please do so we
don't want to 711. yeah so yeah even
though the odds you guys did was better
than the odds they're doing now yes
right that's exactly what i mean it's
funny you brought that up because i had
the people the people were being horses
i said otb takes 20 percent we won't do
that yeah you know so give you a hike
yeah yeah yeah so so okay so now this
whole thing's going on
uh
you
go away 10 years
during this process when you're going
away and you're cooperating are you
cooperating to say what
happened here's what happened i was
fighting and fighting and fighting
my lawyers came to me several times and
i had no interest in going that route
again not to being a hero i just really
didn't i says i'm 30 if i can swing
i saw guys getting 10 12. they kept it
you're not getting that
they're going to start around 20 with
you so i thought well fight it down to
15 or 16. i said you know i'll get out
in my 40s
and
but when
it came out about him
and i got those questions and the next
day i found out from ali they all knew
now i started saying
what am i standing up for
you know i was ready to take 20 years or
whatever you know because i i i did take
the oath at the end uh regardless some
people don't want to believe that for
some reason i don't really care uh but
even without that
i didn't even need that you know i would
would have preferred to take a
reasonable sentence i knew i did some
wrong things and have a choice to move
on when i get out or whatever
so
i didn't have that i didn't feel that
anymore i said now i got to worry about
my kid i have a year old son i so i
called my lawyer and the problem was i
had nothing to give them greg gave him
everything carmine gave him they knew
everything they knew everything and it's
something that's funny i'm going to tell
you greg had told me
years earlier that the day a guy gets
straightened out
the very next day the feds know
i never forgot that
but it came back to me
during the conversation
my lawyers are telling me they even know
you're a little higher up
he must have told his connection that
jimmy and larry came in last night or
two nights ago whatever it was so that's
on record that's a documented thing i
don't you know whatever
all along i was trying to fight that
because that enhances your your sentence
oh no i was a nobody i was a bookmaker
you know but
he told me that he says so
what you can give them they told me what
do you know about the corruption
so
i want to know a lot more than i thought
i knew
and my manager over here my wife
has told me
she lived this part with me and said
there's got to be something you know in
your head that you don't even realize
you know because they will come in years
and years and just kept coming back and
back
but
i had
a secret
frequency code
not me greg had it okay so we were
listening to the fbi through
surveillance on us and our enemies
we had
nobody's gonna you can't pick five
numbers out of your head or seven
numbers whatever it was and land on the
fbi secret code we had it okay
we had
he called we had these old phones
remember the old days the big phones
okay before cell phones
we used to call he used to call somebody
i had those phone records because it was
my sister's phone that i took for she
didn't know what was going on but i need
the phone you know and we would use the
phone during the day and bring it back
to her at night
so
they had the phone records
okay
uh we had
fbi badges and
id cards not filled out with pictures
and everything but out of disposal so
all of these things started leading them
to the fbi not a cop
then
a couple of the fbi agents
put some pieces together
this was one big one
one of the under
not the supervisor who was greg's guy
i'm not mentioning his name only because
people know who it is and he did walk
out he didn't get
convicted so
he's the supervisor one of his agents
brings in
an address for us
brings in an address for vicarina's
hiding place
one day greg has this address
now we can't ask too many questions you
know where'd you get that he says my
girlfriend that's what he always told us
he had vicarina's address where he's
hiding out
we go
it's an empty lot
it was the wrong address
okay
the fbi agent gets this wrong address
hands it to his supervisor
the only other person to get that same
exact wrong address
is greg scarpa
so there's the connection so all this
stuff
you know i gave them led to other things
so there's a whole bunch more there's i
mean a bunch of stuff you know times i
took him to mount sinai hospital to meet
and
i knew they were
agents or detectives because he would go
in and there's a little square in the
room i would watch him because i was
concerned you know i don't know if he's
meeting other wise guys that are looking
you know
and he would sit down and i could just
see
and the way you know you could tell so i
said there's something that's when me
and jimmy started getting worried this
is really tail end of the war too like
you know uh
so
he was uh
he was a magician really he had
everybody everybody fooled and
even that's what greg jr told me who
were you were you assigned uh on the
nikki uh black uh uh uh uh were you on
that uh you so you were on that was that
was you know that was my hit and it was
personal uh
nikki black was
a heavyweight on the arena side he would
have never been of a big heavyweight
respected with persico but when he
became a good fella it was with the
stipulation he would never rise above
soldier okay junior didn't want him
because he bypassed other guys that
should have gotten it the reason is he
was heavy in the teamsters
and money big money so they protected
him early on they made him a a a a good
fella
so he was never going to rise so he
chose vic arena site
as the war was going on
they're not getting any of us
unfortunately most of our guys were
hiding so
not i don't mean greg's crew it was a
media crew and then there was me him and
jimmy were out in the front lines every
day
and
nikki made a comment to my uncle albert
who i mentioned before who was under him
that
tell your nephew butchy that was my
nickname from a kid if he doesn't come
over to our side i'm going to kill him
who's saying this nikki black now he's
telling my uncle albert my godfather
my mom is the sister that's blood i mean
that's tight you're telling him that and
my uncle has done more more work than
nicky may he rest in peace my uncle
albert's done more work than you make
your uncle by far
by far yeah yeah yeah he was very well
respected did you know that did you know
that as a kid i learned more and more
okay i didn't early on but even greg
told me your uncle was with sally d on
this one he was with sally sally
dembrosia was a big name back then too
him sally and junior persico did a lot
of damage in the early years okay and
they went through wards together too so
anyway uh
where are we with this nikki blacks
he tells us if he doesn't come join us
i'm gonna whack
him so now carmine cessa calls us peeps
us we had these beepers back in the day
and we had codes and we that's common
let's meet him at nathan's the code told
us that so we would go meet him and he
told us the same thing
that
oh well
he's the first one to tell us that okay
that he hurt his guy in the club and
nikki's gunning for you
his thing is if he gets me and jimmy or
me or jimmy we crack
and there's nobody out there doing
anything other than us and
you know that would leave greg with
nobody
and they'd win the war
so they were also case in jimmy's uh
tuxedo place
some of nicky's boys so that's much is
true but that night i go to my uncle
albert's house and i says we heard this
he says it's true he says be careful
he says but he i'll never forget this he
looked at me and says but butchie blood
is sticking in water in other words i
didn't have nothing to worry about with
him he says but it is true he's gonna be
careful so i said okay thank you we left
i think it was the next day
but maybe two days me and jimmy differ
on this when we talk about it once in a
while i could have sworn it was the very
next day but maybe the next day we
didn't come into brooklyn the next time
we came into brooklyn
we go back to our spot we've got two
clubs we can watch nikki's funsies and a
couple of other businesses that we know
they come in and out of i got the
binoculars
and we're about a half a block three
quarters of a block away and i see
the toyota pull up and i said there's
nikki black i'll never forget it
and greg says
where let's get him
like just and i think i put in the book
because it's in hindsight it was like
we found our lost dog
there it is you know it's like
there he is we're gonna go kill him and
it was just so normal it's unbelievable
so we start rolling down the block
and he pulls out makes a whole
four-way turn he's coming back the other
way we're behind them and jimmy's sizing
it up we have a fake siren in the window
some coffee cups we want to look like
the binoculars are sitting up there so
it looks like we're law
and to this day i believe that's what he
thought because
during a war how can you let a car pull
up alongside you without even looking
and he was like sort of stiff like he
was telling us his their pulling up now
they're going to pinch us something like
that you know it had to be
we pull up
i'm in the back seat greg is in the
front seat now greg at this point was
getting a little slow
between the aids and dementia and stuff
he wasn't 100 percent
uh he had a one gun on the previous
attempt to with joe waverly uh they
jammed up and then my it was ridiculous
that was an embarrassment that one so
he gets the rifle out he hits the wrong
clip but i'm also with a shotgun coming
out the back window
and
all i hear is his bullets falling out he
hit the wrong clip so the bullets came
out
and the uh he didn't hit the lock thing
so i leaned over and i i mean he never
looked i was really
literally a few inches from what greg
told me to trademark his trademark
behind the ear so it ended here
came out his face i mean it was that's
probably the most horrendous hit of all
that i was ever around uh
but driving away
i i've said this i said you know i'm not
proud of anything i did any of the hits
earlier during the war the war was
self-preservation this was self-defense
to me he's a capable guy he's targeting
me number one
what am i going to do run away most
people would say yeah just leave
but being with greg and being in the
life and i i couldn't so he you know
that one to this day he i say he should
have just behaved himself kept his mouth
shut or came and did it
you alerted me and then what did you
expect you know
that's wild because even nikki black
when you talk nikki black there's you
know
he has he has a reputation he black was
still making blacks yeah did you have
any running with sammy with michael with
any of those guys or no did you
have anything well the only thing with
sammy was during the war we knew
that because we had people that were
siding with us even around john gotti
even though he was with vic or siding
with vic
that vic went to john
to
help with getting greg
first of all that's an embarrassment for
vic to do that go outside the family for
help you should be ashamed of yourself
you're the boss that's the first thing
then john
tells sammy to do it we heard all this
we knew this
so now little by little we're seeing
guys from sami stop in to see us in the
pool room
while they're in there we got four guys
at the front table with guns and
shotguns if they would have even made
any kind of move they would have never
walked out of there we knew we knew that
they were asked to do this
but it never it never came through but i
had this conversation with sammy about
this uh
you know maybe a year ago and i said you
should think about this
you're his underboss
okay you're his number one guy his best
guy your most trusted guy he's going to
send you into the lion's den to kill a
guy like greg during the war with all
his men around armed
why was he putting you in that position
think about that that's the treachery he
might have wanted to get him out of the
picture you know because that's when
they started having their rumblings
about the money and killing everybody
who knows but you don't do that that's
that's you know and he agreed with me
you know we had that discussion he said
you never know you don't haven't thought
about that
and and how how did you guys view samia
at the time sammy is sam well
sammy was always me growing up as a kid
i knew he was a powerhouse
big guy and it happened fast it happened
fast you know he was part of the columbo
family i got to say that and the story i
got was
he was in a nice way asked to leave okay
it's not like he wanted to go somewhere
else there was some kind of thing and uh
the actual word i heard from greg was he
was chased he was told
leave okay somehow or another he latched
on and i'm sure he has his version
whatever it is you know maybe he knows
more i don't know but that's what i know
so he goes and latches on with the
gambinos
eventually gets straightened out before
you know he's a captain
and then all the stuff happened with
castellano and he moved up and he took
took the world over you know
but like back then i liked him i mean
it's not that i dislike him now but you
know we're going in different directions
you know did you have run-ins with him
or no you guys
back then no okay no not really neither
would michael either because it was no
michael i never even met i met his
father once on one of the small
stretches he was out he came to say
hello to greg or maybe he was even on
11th avenue what what happened with greg
the eighth story i mean if you don't
mind sharing that yeah
it's well greg uh used to take
anderson's
three
every night when we're finished at the
club he would go in his pocket they
three honestly like that he won't even
drink milk anything with them just take
him like that he did this every day for
years and years and years and i used to
ask him why so you got a headache he
says no but i don't want to get one and
i'm gonna have a few drinks tonight
so anyway ultimately that
after many many years it is it it
uh caused
also ulcers so i couldn't think of
ulcers in his stomach and one day they
stop bleeding and he's bleeding badly
through the behind and stuff they bring
him to the hospital
and he's losing so much blood
that they called they they needed to
give him a transfusion or in
blood just a is that what it's called a
transmission okay
so
he tells them that he doesn't want the
hospital's blood because of the aids it
was starting to become a problem this is
what you're 86
prime time prime time
so he demands that one of his own men so
we all come in 30 of us men women one
match and it's paulie melly
big weight lifter okay and this was
known as a gay thing back then and i
know you got to be careful things you
say today and but back then that's what
it was known as okay
and paulie was not paulie had more girls
and i mean he was a man's man but
he was a weightlifter and they shed
needles
and that's how he got it and died
later on okay but that was the one match
so he
got paulie's blood
wow now yeah i when i said i got to say
this i don't know if it was divine
intervention
time to pay the piper or
just dumb luck i mean you know but the
one person out of 30 that matched uh
had the virus and he wound up getting
that now because of all the money he had
much like magic johnson he was able to
take all the drugs that they had all the
uh the uh you know some of the drugs
weren't even
proven yet but he said i'll take them
let me try all doctors all over
manhattan i'd be taking him he'd be
getting white blood cells put in this
went on for years and years and years
even through the war
you know so uh
but you know it was it was like i said i
was sad when i heard it but then we
lived with it you know for geez probably
four years and then a couple of years in
the can or whatever around then and then
while i was gone and doing my time i
heard he pissed
yeah and now what was the story they
were saying that he used aids as an
alibi that hey you know it's because of
aids well he could have he could have
you know i i didn't hear that believe it
or not i don't remember hearing that he
used that as an excuse
uh but you know going back to how how he
sold us out because at the end he took a
deathbed confession okay
and he exonerated alley boy and ollie
boy walked out a free man but then got
in trouble again for killing wild bill
and back doing life again
but he could have very easily
added jimmy myself and his son because
that's how he started with this that
greg jr should have never been the head
of that last indictment greg senior
should have how did he not
wasn't listed as the boss so greg got
the kingpin which instead of getting
seven or eight years with drugs at the
time he got 20 plus
and then got hit with more charges later
on uh
but he was not never on he should have
been the head of that indictment you
know so anyway why not say that
why not say
larry and jimmy weren't on these hits
nobody knew nobody was there with us
and say that
they dropped me off sometimes places i
couldn't tell them where i was going
because i was involved in this war and i
went i killed some guys and then they
picked me up later you know he could
have said something to
and obviously death bed confessions
which i didn't know
carry a lot of weight
because ali boy beat his case based on
that
and some of his family members again try
to tell me later on not greg jr because
he's pretty much on my
my wavelength
you know
very hard to forgive and forget
you want to but you can't so we talk
about the good times but we say yeah but
he had us all look what he did to all of
us you know but one of the one of his
daughters told me that
he was so drugged up at the end
that
he
didn't even he just signed whatever they
asked them to sign
but
also now on the other side of that i saw
paperwork i saw a paperwork that
during the war
when he got caught with jimmy throwing a
gun out the car door
it came back to the local police that
was the feds
came back to the local police
that it was larry and jimmy in the car
so he was selling me out right there not
a gun charge i would have took a swim in
a heartbeat you know but you do that
just be you know that's you know i i
don't know if i could do that to
somebody
now
later on i see a forensics an fbi
forensic person show me paperwork
that
the fbi themselves were told
that me and jimmy they knew there was an
informant now they knew there was an
informant now the the head guy knew
obviously who was handling them none of
the underlying guys knew
who it was
they were told it's larry and jimmy
now imagine somebody else in a family
has a connection to the feds they kill
us yeah that's what i'm saying so even
though he might have been whatever there
was a lot of a lot of things he did that
i mean
you know i i can't even understand why i
don't understand it you know just keep
your mouth shut
so that's why you know at the end of the
day where i am now uh
i got no problem looking in the mirror i
got i you know i i was dealt the hand
and i played it you know there when you
when you got out what year was it when
you were done with your time when you
did your time uh 2002 right yeah
what made you not get back what i mean
well the combination of things
even though i don't consider myself uh
exposure of things i didn't like point
fingers and this guy did this this guy
did that
i broke a rule
i dealt with the governor i sat there i
came clean i told him what i knew about
the corruption i got the hits i did you
know so
they're not you know i can't go back for
that reason number one okay number two
there's i i've i see the light there's
no life there anymore
and i try to get messages to some
younger guys that were under us that is
still there i say things i'm on youtube
a lot today
i put things out there i said when are
you going to see the light what are you
you're going to you did eight years now
you got ten and you get out why is it
hard to leave it what what is what
because
the amount of people i've interviewed
and i asked about the glamour of like i
asked leonetti he says dude we didn't
have as good of a time as you think we
did right then i asked michael says no
we did have parties when i was sammy not
really sammy was more to work when i
asked colada you know
so we were we were all about the
business we were all about making sure
you have fun with you were you having
the cars the girls the party and all
that yes i did because i was making an
awful lot of money for 18 19 20 21 22.
you know that's still young you know
right through up until i get so while
you're with linda you're still you're
having a blast with
when i went to prison that's what i lost
to them
seven hundred thousand in eighty-six uh
no no i went away in 92. so but yeah but
up until about 89 yeah and that's uh
between sherlock money uh 700 000 what
you're making what you have in cash that
you left is what you're saying yeah okay
yeah yeah no so we were making but you
know i also overspent not overspent but
like you make
a week we made you know let's set a
business sports business made 60 000.
you know i would always throw greg
something greg jr okay at the beginning
i used to give him a cut but then i saw
him we lost i didn't get any help so i
said okay they get less you know because
it was mine now you know so let's say i
gave them 10 there's 50. you know jimmy
got in there
more and more as years went on he became
a partner uh but i had other people that
worked with me and i never treated them
like workers i treated them like
partners partners yeah so they might not
get an equal but you know so at the end
of the day if i had 15 or 20 for myself
i'd go spend five six seven thousand on
a weekend like it was nothing yeah you
know yeah uh
why but why is it hard to leave i'll
tell you why it's hard and this may not
be nice to some people
some of them can't
survive or find another way to earn a
living okay and a lot of times on these
different things i do i'll sum it up
like this if you know i you know like
michael i know he's i believe he's truly
religious now and wants to leave a
better legacy behind and all some other
guys like that too
i don't feel
comfortable doing that but
i'll say this you don't need that life
to earn a good living or to get respect
and a lot of these guys in it that's the
only way they're going to get respect
and it's the only way they can earn a
living that's why they're still selling
drugs and doing these stupid street
things okay i moved on i when i came
home
i started working in a gym
then i had worked in three gyms
i started developing clients
but i already had the thing in my head
you know once my three years is up okay
i'm gonna find a place of my own which i
did and it kept growing and growing and
growing i have a successful gym met my
wife kelly
we started well she started when she
retired she was a a vice president a
very big government contracting company
when she retired she wanted to do
something that uh
more
less stressful something fun so she
liked promoting weddings she got into
that opened the florist as the base
before you know it we added a wine bar
to the florist
think about the atmosphere flowers all
around
couples ladies would come in a lot we
brought in a little bit of music we were
mobbed
we had to get a bigger place
it turned out to be a supper club
now it got so busy every night that we
were getting home three in the morning i
couldn't go to the gym anymore i still
haven't lost all the weight back
i'm supposed to be a middleweight about
180 i'm still up you know 190 which i
hate but you know i did put on a little
muscle so that's not too bad but
uh we sold that you know and now
i'm back at the gym full-time uh you
know my son's coming in as a trainer i
got five or six other trainers there and
i'm very good to the trainers you know
so they don't go anywhere and they
promote me to other trainers uh
you know i i had three kickboxing
classes i had a
you know
young kid intermediate and adults
and i was full sometimes they were
standing room only you know uh some
cardio classes and i just worked and
worked and worked and you know and i
through the whole time i had the book so
i promoted the book i never got a
publisher to do it and i did the math
myself i said they're going to give me
30 000 or something okay and i'm going
to be begging them for more for the next
10 years until they finish fudging their
numbers you would of course of course
uh i didn't even need a writer to do it
you know because i got an a in writing
in college i wrote that whole book
myself get out of it every bit of it is
my offensive process
the only part i didn't write was the
opening prologues where i wanted uh
somebody that knows me
no no no no no armand is a hell of a guy
he wrote a thing on the back no this was
an ex-cop that uh was on my case so he
wrote described me what he thought of me
and and you know about how i came back
whatever it was very nice but the rest
is mine
and
so i didn't have a writer
i don't have an agent now i do i don't
i don't have uh a publisher
so
i don't have to sell as many
but i'm selling a nice amount thank god
and after this show i'm sure i'm going
to sell some more because i'm going to
tell them my website if it's okay
we're going to put the link to the
website appreciation i appreciate that
but so and when i got to fast forward it
was a perfect segue into de niro
well
he read the book because the same comp
is now one of his security guards
and he said the book was terrific he
asked the guys if they knew anybody that
would come and help them while they're
doing the irishman where he got a lot of
questions they said me
which is
a double-edged sword it's a compliment
but then again the things i got to talk
to him about aren't you know that's you
know uh stuff that i'm not proud of so
anyway i'm his consultant i get a little
part playing a hit man in the movie uh i
want to play in another part uh
joey glasgow or blasco
blasco right joe blasco who is a corrupt
ex-cop working for
joe pesci's character in casino
okay out in vegas and he was uh uh
suspect in the murder
that was a good little part i had
and
coming up you were in casino no not
casino but the story of it was a tv show
called the perfect moment i got you and
i played the corrupt cop
that had it that they made you think he
killed them and the end of the day
nobody still knows who killed them
who pescein casino so i had oscar
goodman on before
who's from casino pesci uh because she
was playing home tony spelatre
colada was the
hitman on the vice that he
did what he did yeah that's right that
so all of this has led me now to being
uh there's a new network coming out okay
uh there's a soft opening coming next in
october the grand opening will be al
capone's birthday early january uh i
will be hosting a tv talk show and it's
called mob tv it's the name of the uh
the network uh it's on the infamous tv
and then mob tv 24 7.
and we may name it the life
uh and our people on much like we're
doing today hopefully i'm as good as you
as a as a you know on the other side of
the table and uh
we also have other projects in
development like mobsters versus
monsters
four
ex-mob guys
that truly believe
and go looking
for the paranormal like bigfoot and
things like that but it's it's serious
and it's funny it's a good little mix
it's sort of reality it's hilarious yeah
so there's that we have a couple of
other people that are gonna come on the
show when i do it that have you know uh
some podcasts in the works and uh
different things like that so i'm in a
whole different direction now i i'm
part-time at my gym and i'm doing this
stuff more i got to do a reading
this week sometime for the
there's a word he used but i guess
certain uh marketing things commercials
and stuff for mob tv they want me to do
the the talking as the actor party so
what are they going to go pay michael
madsen or armand asante you can do it so
anyway so there's so much happening that
you know i'm sorry i got a question for
you larry so please why why are
so many mobsters great storytellers what
is that all about like do you guys go to
before you become made they send you to
this low-key you know cia fbi 17 keys to
being a great storyteller like you know
such a unique ability to tell stories
you know what i think it is maybe that's
the little dna thing
that
brings us all together at some point
where you know everybody thinks it's
this we're vicious killers or where this
they're all the same maybe it's that we
have this sort of sight to us where
we're not
we're a little wiser than people think
well you know it's not maybe yeah
there's not a maybe you know you know uh
but but the wise yeah people think like
like i guess you said somebody said it's
not that glamorous it's not all easy
it's not it's a lot of hard work all
those rackets took a lot of work a lot
of dedication uh you had us you know be
forceful sometimes but
uh
but that's a great question because
there are a bunch of us out there now
isn't there yeah i wonder what is this
like you guys could do a clinic a master
class on storytelling and they just
haven't answered that yeah
have you noticed this like you know
like you sit there you tell the stories
you know one time i'm a pf chance in
santa monica bad analogy but i'm just
giving you two you'll see where this
goes
and i used to go to the same pf changs
and i would always sit all the way in
the uh to the right at santa monica and
i would go
right after i went to the stairs in
santa monica i would go to matador beach
and i'd come here i'd have my seven
arnold palmers i would read my book and
do my plan for the week and go back home
this was routine every sunday right
one day my bar my bartender the waiter
he's written a book i said what book are
you reading says well i'm really trying
to get better with uh
women i'm really struggling with that i
said okay great i mean what book you're
reading he says the wisdom of a
prostitute what so he's reading this
book
i'm like what a title of a book what's
the wisdom of a prostitute he says well
this prostitute is telling the story
of her experience with 2000 right
and she's saying the weakness the
insecurities of all these men and i have
so many insecurities as a man and so
she's sharing with me that
90 of men have similar insecurities and
it's making me get this confidence right
so i said what better
person to learn about men's insecurities
than a prostitute because she's been
weird right now you know she has that
wisdom i mean it is a wise woman and
not that's not psych 101 no no no no no
no that's it
at first when he tells me this story i'm
like you know that's a that's a pretty
strange thing to be reading yourself
right but the way he's explaining the
stories okay maybe this makes sense okay
but you know maybe the reason why you
guys are so good at telling stories is
because
how many times you have to go to a sit
down
where you know you have to measure the
words you use and be you have to be
careful with the words so you get your
it's almost like every one of the
mobsters pacing on how you speak is the
same speed you guys are not fast talkers
really you know
and it's just like musical the way you
go with the pacing you know what else i
think it is now you said that and and i
i mean this
there are a lot of unique stories
everybody has a little play a little
spin on their story okay
and they start telling it so much it
becomes second nature you know what i
like about us today and
we didn't go totally chronological i
didn't start i was a kid which i did but
then we sort of bounced and i like that
better i think it leads that's why when
you do watch the mob museum show i
started it where i am now and went back
you know uh
because if i say it over and over and
then and then god forbid i say there
were five of us there somebody will call
me up and say oh they got a podcast you
said four you know you're like under a
microscope you know
then you find haters you find haters out
there i mean i'm so lucky i got so few
some of them unfortunately are all
friends that
it you don't understand you can't
understand it is it envy because i'm
moving on or
uh these friends are still in the life
or they haven't left the life no the
ones that are still in the life love me
got it i talked to a bunch of them and
they loved me uh i was away with the
boss of one of the families at the tail
end of my sentence and hated anybody
talking negatively about me stood behind
me a hundred percent
complained wanted to kick the dirt and
spit on the ground when greg's name came
up he said he roomed so many good men
you know
uh
but no it's guys that are now out of the
life
and they're lost they don't know what to
do with themselves so
they gotta you know have something bad
to say but i have one oh friend that
wasn't even in the life he was
impersonating me on tick tock
to try to pick up girls
this is true and you know how i found
out one of the girls called me and told
me his number
we reached them
and he just broke down on the phone
crying i didn't know what i was doing
but i mean just ridiculous why did it
work dude that's the question i don't
think so it's effective i don't think so
because my cousin alby's son
called this kid up
and
i'm not you know to be
mean
he's very overweight now he's losing all
his hair he's a little younger than me
and
my cousin said what were you thinking he
says okay so say you pull it off
they see a picture he's putting pictures
of me out this is me this is me
he says
when they're expecting larry to get out
of the car and you pull up
how are you gonna explain that he says i
don't know i'm just losing my mind i
mean it was just hysterical i'm not even
mad at the guy anymore i mean at first i
was i'd say but
you know
well you look hollywood man you look
like you you belong in hollywood you got
that look thank you so much thank you
and it's been very interesting uh
learning uh about your story uh i
accidentally got into interviewing folks
from your life and from the first one
after michael it's just been you know
one after another and i know your story
was it was popping up all over the place
the last year year and a half i kept
saying
very much it is like i said it's unique
it's true i mean every bit of it is true
i always say this
there could be things that other people
live with me that remember differently
like even jimmy i told you like i said
it was the next day
yeah oh wait he didn't get hit until the
third you said it was the second you
know that's gonna happen yeah you know
i've said well don't you remem and i use
jimmy a lot because i'll say didn't we
go to this meeting and there's like 15
of us there he's 15. the whole freaking
family was there was like 50 guys and
maybe we're thinking of two different
meetings you know but we had 120
meetings during the war maybe more
four a day for six months everywhere we
had to go travel all over it was a
nightmare that was a nightmare it was
almost a relief did you do anything with
the philadelphia guys or no
no
no i met a few while i was away uh but
not really uh my my thing was basically
brooklyn manhattan new york yeah yeah so
well we're gonna put the link to the
book below
life a brooklyn
boy is seducing to the dark world of
mafia larry mazza appreciate you coming
out i really
i'll come back for part two if you want
yeah once you do the other stuff i look
forward to it that's what i did yeah
that's happening soon so
thank you again any time thank you
appreciate it what a great storyteller
right larry mazza anyways if you enjoyed
this interview we did a podcast as well
with michael francis and samuel garvano
on a different channel if you've never
seen that probably one of the best
conversations we ever had click here for
sammy click here for michael if you
enjoyed the interview give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel take
care everybody bye
[Music]